okay good evening I'm sorry about the
slight delay there are some
complications this evening welcome to
planning West anyway my name is Justin
carriage I'm the chair - in front of me
are the other counselors who are making
decisions today - either side of me are
offices of the council who will assist
us in those decisions and if I could ask
them to introduce themselves please
chambers legal services good evening my
name is Dale Barker on the Planning
Manager in my role as an impartial
advisor to the committee I think I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal Town
Planning Institute and planning
committee members are not bound by the
case officers recommendation Victoria
tried away Senior Planner Alex cosmetic
Senior Planner Charlotte Senior Planner
Amy fleet planner lovely thank you I'm
not sure where I do this on the agenda
but I would like to welcome councilor
Perry who has stepped in to fill a
vacancy which arose under such
circumstances but thank you very much
for joining our committee so if we go
through the agenda apologies for absence
great and I think council Giles will be
arriving late she said she will any
disclosures of interest council organ
thank you first of all 1802 582 I
objected to the outline applications are
only concerned with detail not the
principle of the development which has
already been approved as such I'm
satisfied that I can take part of the
consideration of the application
and I've come to the meeting with an
open mind about considering the
application and also agenda item 1802
six for one I will be leaving the room
as a member of the District Council
cabinet thank you thank you thank you
chair same two applications but for
different reasons I've received email
correspondence on both I'm assuming
that's the same for everyone in the
committee so worth making the point of
that item seven eighteen zero two three
nine three ful I'm the warm member are
we stepping out and making my
representations
similarly on so council which what's
that what's it called
item 7 Kings meet item number eight
application 1801 o0 ful i'm the ward
member I haven't made representations
but I understand that there might be
some cancer Harry thank you thank you
good evening chair
I am the county councillor for the wells
borne division which incorporates Kings
Kings Mead farm but I'm coming to this
evenings meeting with an open mind okay
just I'm stepping away from the table
for the first item on the agenda what's
the first part of the first item on the
agenda which deals specifically with the
red edge Gateway project and that will
be Molly Giles if she gets here chairing
that so that's all the those discourage
of interest again I just like to say
thank you to counter to Crump to
stepping in as as as a substitute
tonight so the minutes of the last
meeting do we accept those agreed
thank you and
can just remind me to get those before I
rush off so the order of business
tonight that was a complicated thing
which delayed us slightly as I said I
would like councillor Giles as the vice
chair to run that as she has been
dealing with it instead of me or that
all the way through since she's been by
his chair so if she does get here we'll
bring that in when she arrives so that
is being put back item number four is
being put back yet to do and we'll bring
that in when when we can there is here
we go what is it I'm thinking of Green
Acres at Earl's wood so Green Acres at
else would item nine has no
representation from objectors or anybody
so I am suggesting we bring that forward
with a recommendation for me that we
delegated we are capable so so we
brought it forward
I wait all those in favor of delegating
it to officers yep unanimous I'm taking
that I'm accepting that that's good and
the other application is is item number
eight I'm not going to bring the actual
application forward as yet I'm going to
leave it where it is in the agenda but
there is an outstanding site visit for
this which we haven't done we couldn't
we couldn't make it
we couldn't get people to to attend
we couldn't find a date to a suitable I
don't think there's anyone in the
audience who's actually here for that
application at the moment but I might
okay
I'd like to make an apology as the chair
that that's what's happened we arranged
a sign meeting and it's failed to matter
and that's wasting a lot of different
people's time and I am very sorry about
that well I am going to bring forward is
a suggestion that as the site visit is
outstanding that we vote that we can
continue that forward that we arrange
tonight to make that site visit and
defer again
this item without hearing it so that
that's what I'm going to suggest I'm
going to suggest that we vote now to to
either go on or okay so if you I'm not
making it very clear but what I'm trying
to say is do we want to defer the item
again without hearing it and go on the
site visit okay discuss that before we
go on so we'll take a vote on if we
defer all those in favor of deferring
yet again this item as suggested by the
warm member please go now all those
against and all those abstaining so we
will defer item number eight okay so
apologies for having made you come here
but I think eventually we get where we
should be
so now we can go back and find out where
we are in the agenda and I think it's
number five am i right Dale application
number 1805 eight - oh dear which has
come back we've seen this before last
time
Arden Heath Farm Loxley Road
stratford-upon-avon now the specific
reasons that this has come back to us
and I'm hoping that in the officer
report those will be really highlighted
as well as the the presentation being
given because we need to know why it's
come back after we made our decision
last time Thank You chair just going to
start with a very brief summary of the
case so this is a reserved matters
application for 135 dwellings submitted
pursuant to outline reference 14 double
O two six two out which granted planning
consent for up to two hundred and
seventy dwellings across the Arden Heath
farm site the approved outline consent
was subject to a section 106 agreement
which included provisions for 35%
affordable housing large library
contributions education contributions
the provision of on on-site play spaces
contributions to improvements to the
footpath healthcare contributions and
the significant contribution towards
works towards the Clopton bridge this
reserved matters application was submit
has been submitted as the first of three
house building phases for the overall
site additionally two other phases have
been submitted under separate
applications which relate to green
infrastructure and to the sustainable
urban drainage system for the site the
phasing strategy having been agreed as a
discharge of condition to the outline
concern in no applications for reserved
matters have yet been determined on this
the black dot shown here is located
roughly centrally over the entire
outline application and isn't over the
reserved matters site which is showing
more clearly here on
slide members will be aware that this
game was heard on the 5th of December
and at that committee meeting you
resolved to refuse planning consent a
decision hasn't yet been issued on this
current application this is because
following committee officers reflected
that members were not made fully aware
of the consequential impact that a
refusal would have both on the viability
at this site being port forward and on
the consequent impact on the housing
delivery across the district in relation
to the council's five-year housing land
supply both of these matters are
material considerations that should be
considered in reaching a view on this
proposal it is a material consideration
that condition 3 of the outline planning
consent required that reserved matters
pursuant to the outline consent should
be submitted by the 5th of December 2018
that date has now passed so in the event
of refuse all the applicant would not
have the opportunity to submit an
amended reserved matters application
seeking to address any any refusal
reasons given it's only a reserved
matters application pursuant to the
original outline that can be considered
in line with the parameters set out in
that outline and only development
approved through a reserve matters
application pursuant to the outline that
can be subject to the agreed section 106
as such of them through the successful
appeal other than through a successful
repeal determination the consequence of
refusal would be that the developer
would need to submit a new for a new
outline of fall planning application if
they wish to pursue housing on their
site unlike the outline consent that was
previously approved any new application
would be still liable and that's very
likely to have a bearing on the
viability at the site as a whole
additionally housing delivery across the
district is a material consideration and
my colleagues in policy team have
advised me that the current six point
two six year housing land supply for the
council assumes delivery of 70 houses
from their site commencing in 2021
stroke 2022 this was on the basis that
the site had outlined
and was considered to be deliverable
within the five-year period for that
calculation refusal of this reserved
matters application would immediately
remove seventy 12 eggs from the supply
and would question the deliverability of
the site to the extent of removing the
site from its entirety as the council
would be unable to argue that an outline
consent where reserved matters had been
refused was deliverable so I don't
intend to go through the full details of
the dispute again given that this was
only heard in December but by means of a
summary and because all matters have to
be considered in a round and the
five-year house announced apply
viability and the details of the
proposal put forward this is the
application site this is the layout the
area shaded in pink on the plan that you
can see our phases four and five housing
which are not for consideration here and
have been submitted under a separate
application which has yet to be
determined the access to the site was
agreed at outline and is offered the
Loxley road coming southwards and the
site is designed around a spine road
coming to the south of the site which
would be tree-lined the applicant had
broadly considered the context of the
area understood that there were three
broad character areas the character
areas being the Loxley Road open space
areas and then the areas more internal
to the site and had this come up with
variations to the house types proposed
based on those character differences
these were images provided by the
applicant showing at the top the Loxley
Road these being the houses proposed
under this phase to scheme these being
indicative houses as shown for latter
phases that haven't yet had any
determination and these been existing
houses on the Loxley roads that that
would be the street scene as proposed
and these two are internal Street views
of the site and here just for context
are houses that exist among the Loxley
Road
which so vast array of architectural
styles we have bungalows we have a
two-story properties we have bay windows
cap slide roof gable ended roots dormer
bungalows render detailed brick
detailing some have header detail some
have sill details there is a wide
variety of detailing and then finally
this is an image of the existing site as
seen from the end of the Loxley Road the
site is to the south of the Loxley Road
and just beyond the access to the odd
and Heath farm complex are shown there
I do have further details I can provide
during technical questions if anyone
would like them at that stage chairman
updates have been provided in the update
sheet which are material to the
consideration of this application the
original officer recommendation was is
as presented at the 5th of December and
was to grant members at that meeting did
resolve to refuse planning consent
members are now asked to reconsider this
application in light of the material
considerations in relation to the timing
of the reserved matters application and
the impact that refusal therefore has on
the viability of this team and on the
five-year housing land supply had me
reflected on this additional material in
from information members will first need
to consider whether they wish to rescind
their previous determination to refuse
in the event that the refusal is
rescinded the members have the option to
either defer this application with the
view of the applicant working with
officers on the wall member to achieve a
better design quality scheme in line
with the clear guidance given at the
previous committee or whether they wish
to approve the concern in line with the
original officer recommendation thank
you great thank you
good point yeah so obviously I start at
the the meeting that determines this my
initial direction was to defer for the
reasons that have been set out in the
papers here we were told at that point
that we weren't in a position to be able
to defer for those reasons that it would
be unreasonable for us to do that and
that we should either choose if it's
basically if the quality wasn't good
enough to refuse or if we found the
quality is acceptable to approve we
obviously didn't find it acceptable and
therefore a huge on this deferral matter
what's changed why we've now being told
that we are able to defer on the reasons
that I gave last time when it's a very
good question I've certainly gone over
this with with the officers and and the
reason it's come back to us is in
consultation with me so this isn't being
thrown at us it's in consultation with
the chair and I was very very happy to
have this come back to us but I would
like an officer response to that
question I think the advice is it's
always better to have a decision where
you can have a decision and with the
deferral you need to know what it is
that you're looking to achieve from that
deferred situation however reflecting on
the committee we honestly felt that
members hadn't been made fully aware of
the timing of the reserved matters
implication and the impact that that
would have on five-year housing land
supply and that you would have to submit
an outline or full application going
forward so the issues of design and
everything else that were raised are
steel material but they all need to be
taken in the balance with that
additional information that's being
provided now I know we're going but well
okay I that doesn't actually change the
fact that nothing's changed as far as
why we can defer however deferring is
better than refusing and although a
decision is preferable
you know deferring is better than
refusing in this case I think in
officer's opinion and I am very happy to
give this committee the chance
to to come to that decision if it wishes
okay one more point taken
I think reinforces the point I just made
so second part of this the outline was
originally for 270 properties as you've
pointed out we have another 135 coming
forward to a different scheme if that's
a proof and it would be approved within
the time scales then presumably that
makes that outline extent and then for
this can become forward any time in the
future the word the wording of condition
3 is that reserve matters should be
submitted prior to the three years from
the date that the consent was granted so
although that if consent were granted
for the roommate the the remainder
balance that doesn't mean that any
further reserve matter applications come
in they they have to be submitted prior
to that date regardless of whether
there's a provable refusal of any other
matters at that time given these were
because the result surely that they've
met that condition our advice is know
that you can't that the wording is that
any reserved matter each in it every
single reserve butter has to be
submitted prior to that date that's
that's clear good thank you for asking
that how about just on that point miss
Jo and I voted propose deferral then it
was refused
I have spent two hours on this
application yesterday come through every
house and it's a lot worse than I
thought
well I'm concerned refusal is an option
okay right okay can I ask members now if
they've read the update sheet on this I
know we're going this is not a normal
application so I just want to make sure
people are aware of everything there's a
very short letter from the applicant
which is worth reading probably worth
they're members of the public reading as
well
yeah yeah so yeah I'm sorry we've Chuck
stuff in which doesn't normally go in we
will now go to the speakers and the
first speaker tonight is the Town
Council so if we can hear from Jenny
Fred Lee stratford-upon-avon Town
Council who's objecting you have three
minutes good evening thank you Jeff I
certainly won't need that length of time
because because of the previous
discussions what I'd like to say is the
Town Council's main concerns are about
housing mix in that the mix and the core
strategy had been applied rather than
the Knicks and the recently adopted
neighborhood plan which is more suitable
for trans needs I fully understand the
difficulties with the application of
housing mix two developments already
without line planning permission and
actually feel this is an area that needs
further discussion exploration in the
future I would propose a deferment to
this application so that these and other
concerns can be discussed and a better
understanding of design edge of town
planning and other matters can be agreed
with residents and developers I would
actually ask you to defer this
application thank you from what I
remember of last last year's discussion
it's it is unfortunate about the mix
that's something that we have to decide
on in the outline application as you
know we all know now we didn't know then
so going forward you're quite right I
think this council has learned it's
lessons as have presumably lots of other
councils across the country but if it is
deferred it does give you an opportunity
to talk about at least the design
aspects thank you are there any
questions no thank you and for the
objectors Kate Rolf on behalf of
residents Association also three minutes
if you need it
I've got nothing further to add to the
previous speech on the 5th of December
apart from the fact that this
application should be refused however
should Taylor Wimpey not give clear
concrete assurances of fundamental
changes to the scheme in respect of
better quality design the utilization of
higher quality materials and a reduction
in the density of the dwellings then we
would respect respectfully ask the
Planning Committee to maintain their
current position of refusing the
application taylor WIMP his agent will
follow me and I would ask you to ask her
if this is the case and not just empty
promises we are prepared to give them
the opportunity to make changes and if
that can't be achieved that it should be
refused
we need those assurances and so do you
as a committee thank you thank you any
questions can Atkinson yes I think we as
a working group would because the
alternative of a refusal is extremely
complicated complicated and it's always
be careful what you wish for
thank you very much no more questions
Thank You councillor and now to the
applicants served their planning and
Allison FAC hello you have six minutes
if you wish it thank you chair
officers have provided you with a
comprehensive background to the reserved
matters applications and you're aware
from your report of the history of the
site I think it's important to note that
during the original appeal the inspector
considered in full the effect of the
development of the site on matters such
as the local area the highway network
and residential immunity to this end he
attached robust safeguarding conditions
restricting for example the heights of
the Devourer
and he approved any parameters planned
limiting the extent extent of the
development parcels and ensured a 10
meter wide landscape buffer to be
incorporated around the development to
impart protect living conditions of
existing occupiers and the visual
intrusion into the open countryside I
need to stress to you that Taylor Wimpey
wish to continue to work within these
approved parameters adhering to the
proved master plan and to assure to
ensure that safeguarding principles
secured at that outlined stage are
maintained as a site now identified for
housing in the newly adopted
neighborhood plan Taylor Wimpey
are committed to the delivery of the
site and welcome this opportunity to
assure members as requested by
councillor of that all of those matters
still to be determined can be looked at
afresh with the working group local
councillors the Town Council in order to
ensure that along with officers Planning
Committee can be satisfied that they're
able to support the applications this
will incorporate among among other
matters examining the relationship of
existing properties with new dwellings
the density of pockets of the layout the
appearance of the street scene and the
use of materials and design features and
I can also confirm that additional
design work will be informed by further
detail design appraisals and consent
contextual analysis in the form of
design review in response to the
comments that have been made I trust
that you are able to accept that you
have the assurance requested by
councillor offer that is the case
members attention as has already been
drawn to the update report which also
sets out from Taylor Wimpey themselves
the solid assurance in respect to
further engagement with the working
group and a commitment to exploring
options for design and layout of the
site maintaining an open dialogue on the
current reserved matters applications
alongside discussion
spitfyre about the remaining phases will
also enable a speedy resolution and
delivery of new homes to Stratford in
turn the benefits secured through the
106 as identified by the officers will
also be available to be utilized I can
also confirm that a working group
meeting is scheduled for the middle of
January to look at the other phases of
the site which themselves are in part
reliant on parts phases one and two
coming forward and Taylor Wimpey also
recognized the benefits to planning
committee of considering all the phases
together to achieve a cohesive view of
the design and I can again assure you
that that that request from the working
group will be honored and you've got my
undertaking that that will happen in
summary therefore members are
accordingly requested to defer the
application to enable Taylor Wimpey to
re-engage with the working group to
achieve a higher standard of design good
connectivity and to secure the safe
environment for future road users which
were the items that were sought at the
previous hearing committee thank you
very much thank you very much and thank
you for the for the letter in your
statement of intent to engage and I'm
glad that the the residence you'll be
working with
through the ward member and others have
have come up with something concrete at
least to start those discussions the
list of of questionable aspects which we
had at the last committee and indeed
have at this committee it's a good
starting point to work with so you
several questions in a row you are
prepared to change the layout yes to
some extent I was really pleased that
you will be working and maybe bear to
show how you've worked and cooperated
with what's going to be on the other
side of the road because it just seems
so silly not to come forward with okay
thank you
any other questions Kassar bombs
the Chairman on one of the committee
should go on or whether it should come
back well I was going to say was I've
been through okay
the rest of it is bland stuck together
and from there they're all stuck
together it's atrocious I'm just putting
my point of view to the lady that my
feelings
Julie noted I'm sure councillor Richards
evening clearly a deferral is going to
delay putting space in grounds
realistically how long is it going to
take you to work with the groups that
you've you've mentioned councillors and
the working group to bring forward a
revised scheme that would be acceptable
to the majority it will take as long as
it takes we want to be able to persuade
all members that the scheme has been
improved from a level that that we were
content with and officers were content
with to make that difference for you
so we would anticipate that it would be
within the space of four or five months
I would imagine okay no more questions
thank you very much and we can now hear
from the ward member hence the role
five minutes if you need them thank you
we've heard what Taylor Wimpey have said
and I would ask that as well as Taylor
Wimpey addressing all the reasons for
refusal given on the 5th of December
that you asked him to look at reducing
the number of houses and therefore
easing congestion on the site and taking
up some of the concerns that council
answers and that Taylor Wimpey look at
the housing mix and providing more
bungalows as in the neighborhood
development plan policy also that since
last Thursday's planning training on
landscape which some of you attended
Taylor Wimpey and the planner look at
addressing the focal point of the house
on the hill and ensuring that this will
remain as such part of the landscape I
would also want to show and since that
list of conditions forwarded to you all
on the 5th of December are put into
place I reiterate that this should be
refused unless you are absolutely
satisfied that Taylor Wimpey will now
work with us and the Town Council to
come up with a well designed and better
layout scheme with potentially less
properties if all the reasons for
refusal cannot be addressed by Taylor
Wimpey then it should be refused however
once again we are prepared to sit around
the table with a blank sheet of paper
paper we all need to understand the
consequences of a refusal thank you
thank you and I'm going to drift into
comment here because I don't think we
can go to a blank piece of paper here
we're looking at a deferral to alter a
certain amount some aspects of of what
is largely before us we can't have a new
application without having a new
application you know so we're not going
back to basics we are tinkering to get
the best possible application similar to
this that we can and we have heard that
you know there's a possibility to move
to move things around somewhat which i
think is good we are debating and
debating debating with the councillor
are there any actual questions no thank
you thank you very much
technical questions I think yes
counselor wishes so this is obviously
come back to us because the impact it
could have on our five-year has a night
supply for the reviews realistically if
we're deferring we've heard it's going
to take a minimum of four to five months
most likely 4-minute four to five months
to bring forward a revised application
that in itself concerns me given it's
taken three years to get what we've got
if we are delayed by let's say six
months give it half a year how is that
going to impact our five-year housing
land supply given we've allocated this
for 2122 the honest answer to that is I
don't know the answer to that question
clearly it's worked out in a five-year
period and a small delay is going to
have an impact but but it being refused
in totality is likely to have a bigger
impact that's probably the best answer I
can give you without referring back to
my colleagues in policy can't stop
bouncing only two months did they what I
was going to ask will this come back to
committee yes it would need to come back
to committee and obviously a deferral
it's just that it's a deferral for you
to what I'm saying to you is we're going
to defer it all with there's a
possibility that we come back with a
different scheme now are we going to
come back to this committee and go
through it again and see if the things
that we put forward although I didn't
actually support the refusal have been
addressed because that's very important
I don't normally spend two hours on an
application but I did feel that as if
there was a lot of concern I would look
at it properly and there is a lot of
problems and absolutely that's the point
a deferral it is just that if when it
comes back you minded that not enough
progress has been made you absolutely
have the option to refuse at that stage
all of deferral does is give you the
opportunity to consider amendments that
are made at that point in time I just
point out that first thing we have to do
today is to decide if we want to leave
it as it is and you know we could leave
it as a refusal or if we want to rescind
that decision so we can make a new
decision when we make the new decision
we could approve it but you know I think
that would be rather odd so although
there is new information to consider so
it's most likely if we were sind the
refusal we would I would be pushing
towards a deferral but it's just just
the process that was coming forward
councillor organ Thank You chairman I
think everyone seems to be sort of
singing off the same hymn sheet here and
the reason why we're here is to achieve
quality so we're still in questions even
I'm sorry yeah if we finished questions
do you know where you're coming from and
I don't think there's a specific point
but I think if we got to a point where
everything had changed where we had a
different road layout completely we had
very different housing proposal that's a
different application something that's
of a lower density of a higher quality
design is is but still within the same
vein that this application is the same
application but yeah I'm afraid it's a
woolly thing so yeah I think actually
that's good that that answers the scope
is actually larger than I inferred -
councillor Rolf okay there is quite a
considerable scope for the sentence of
it from what you say which is which is
reassuring so when the parties go away
we're just going to send them away
presumably would this be controlled by
officer
by what's the process go forward so that
it can be as efficient and quick as
possible so to date there has been an
informal working group which is
comprised myself the developer and board
counselor and going and a couple of
local residents and going forward to
include the Town Council we would just
look to me discuss the issues that have
been raised at Planning Committee
previously the issues that we wish to be
addressed I think it would then be for
the developer to go away consider all of
that come back with an alternative
proposal and possibly at that stage to
consider that again before we go out to
recon saltation I would see it as an
informal process and it would be to the
developer to determine when they brought
it back to Planning Committee when they
feel that they have done enough to
address the issues and for you to then
consider it I don't think it would be
appropriate for me okay so you're happy
with that yeah with the process any more
questions for Richard um I'll come
before I ask this or not homes in 2021
to likely impact is it significant or is
it I think it's how it how it then gets
looked at overall so if this scheme
doesn't go ahead there is a genuine
likelihood that the entirety of this
game doesn't go ahead so the whole whole
270 so whilst I can't guarantee that
that's the case that is a possibility
before you go on I'm going to ask why
why would this make the whole thing for
because the whole thing is wrapped up in
the section 106 agreement originally
agreed obviously that that's based on a
viability of delivering 270 dwellings if
you only deserve 135 that viability
starts to become very questionable so
whilst at this moment in time nobody has
presented me with full viability of the
scheme I think it's quite likely that
only providing 135 he's not going to be
viable to is unlikely to be viable to
provide the works though crops and
bridge and everything else going forward
and so those those cost would have been
shared amongst the two developers across
the entirety of the
I'm told by policy but if the entirety
of the site disappears that has an
impact I think it was on point three yes
I can't remember so it it starts to have
a bearing point three seven years yeah
okay so Perry Thank You chair the
question I wanted to ask the actual
outline application is for up to 270
dwellings but you keep talking about 270
dwellings the question I want to relate
back to on this particular section
bearing in mind the ward members
comments are we are we talking 270 in
total for the two because the outline
says up to 270 so we can the design can
come back for for less than number it
doesn't have to be it's not set in stone
it's 135 for this particular section
could you just give me some
clarification on that thank you
absolutely so the outline consent was
put up to 270 the developer has come
forward for half of that on this and the
entirety of the site for the two phases
but all the phases are for the entire
number but there is nothing to stop the
developer for to come forward with less
if that achieves a better density mix
and everything else and I think that
that argument has been heard okay Thank
You councillor Barnes and then if we
could move on to do with the traffic
lights which all of the bonds along the
road are being affected the 106 didn't
go forward so if this scheme falls away
then obviously the section 106 that was
approved
also falls away and so the sum that was
agreed for the Clopton bridge falls away
that is part of one sum and
yeah absolutely so long Marsden and me
in Vail also provide contributions to
that so it could have a knock-on impact
on the delivery of those sites as well
there's a lot of variables here moving
parts okay can we move to debate and
cash walk I won't start again I'll carry
on from where I was I think the
objective outcome really is to achieve a
quality scheme and if the various
parties are happy to work together to
bring something back that might be more
acceptable to this committee then I
don't think it's our purpose to obstruct
that so I would be quite prepared to
propose rescinding the the refusal on
the grounds that a different reason
might lead to a more speedy and whatever
outcome thank you thank you noted
councillor Richards Thank You chair this
has been nothing short of a shambles we
have considered this application when we
considered it we consider to defer and
then discuss the reasons for that we
were told at that point very clearly
that our reasons for deferral were
unreasonable and given the number of
issues that we had the most appropriate
action would be to refuse we ended up
refusing this has come back to us
because of a potential issue with a
five-year housing land supply now as
we've just been told by our face off so
very helpfully if the entirety of the
side has 272 double what we're looking
at now it doesn't come forward that has
an impact of naught point three seven
years on a housing supply we currently
have six point two six so we're in quite
a comfortable position as far as I can
see as I say we're talking about half so
let's say at worst 0.2 it's probably
closer to 0.175 but let's say point two
I don't think that's entirely
significant we've have reserve starts
coming forward
I don't think that's entirely
significant as to the viability argument
whilst I accept there could be viability
issues that's a business risk that's not
a council planning that was a business
risk both parties have had plenty of
time to bring forward an appropriate
development an appropriate scheme that
we could approve the last minute we've
had an absolute assurance from the CEO
of Taylor Wimpey that they are committed
to this site regardless of whether we
defer or refuse that commitment is still
there if we were to refuse I have no
doubt in my mind that teller Wimpey
would submit a full application and go
ahead and conduct the consultation
they've assured us they will do today on
that site and at that point we can then
consider whether we do or don't approve
that full application but what we've
gotten now to my mind is utterly
unacceptable in terms of design as we've
laid out at a previous meeting if we
defer now we have to review it again
when we come back to committee if it's
still not acceptable do it suffer again
and again and again and again until we
end up with an entirely revised scheme
that doesn't even closely resemble what
we're looking at now which will have the
same impact on our five-year housing on
surprise it would do if we refused now
and had a new application brought
forward at a later date
if it's not right simply it's not right
I'm entirely uncomfortable going back on
a decision that we've already been made
given the information that we were given
at that time and that we've had sense
and I would be comfortable sticking with
the refusal as was laid out before I
won't be supporting a deferral okay
sorry
Thank You chair obviously I'm new to
this application this evening I do find
it very refreshing that the developer is
prepared to work closely with the
working party I would also like just to
say that whilst we do have a five-year
housing land supply that is also subject
to a 20% buffer which actually takes us
up to six years if I
correct five years plus a 20% buffer so
actually we are much closer to the limit
on the housing land supply and in view
of the impact that it is going to happen
I think the fact that the developer
wants to work with the working parties
and the town council to get a better
design get the right housing mix it's a
much better way forward and I think the
writing's on the wall as far as Taylor
Wimpey is concerned well aware of the
Spitfire development Spitfire a renowned
for a very high quality development and
if if all parties can get together then
I feel the sensible route is to defer
thank you any other councillor bands
don't they do well you know last time I
did proposed a very richard ii ii we
didn't go along that way i've looked at
it since i cannot understand why this
application had been sitting there for
three years of no discussion between the
applicant it is appalling and looking at
it more seriously which i did the other
day and thanks to the senior officer
there let me have all the paperwork and
went through it i'm the 106 agreements
and everything it is appalling for rapid
now i'm just concerned that we've been
spent three years doing nothing can we
get it right in the short time that's
why i asked whether it was going to come
back to committee for the simple reason
you know but um I'm happy to refuse you
so I didn't catch that last but you're
happy to what chemists refer I'm happy
for it to be refused I don't think
that's okay it moved thank you okay
catch the crop I also again want you to
to this application but on the balance
of probability
reasonableness I'm happy to support the
organs proposal to rescind and defer
sounds like a second second yeah okay so
that was a rescind I think we have to do
have to do in two parts what can we say
were sinned and deferred to have to do
rescind two parts so with a view to do
differential of both councilor organ are
you suggesting we rescind our previous
decision to refuse this application I
believe that was what I said I didn't
make any comment on what might happen
after that I believed it is - okay good
thank you
you're seconding that lovely so we have
a proposal to rescind our previous
decision to refuse this application if
you want to keep it as a refusal then
you're not in favor of this all those in
favor of rescinding our previous
decision all against okay so we have
resolved to rescind our previous
decision can I have another cancer organ
I will not be very wordy it is purely a
proposal to defer the application to
give the applicant and the various
parties an opportunity to resolve the
design issues with the application thank
you to have a second for that councillor
Perry thank you so all those in favor of
deferring please vote now all those
against and abstentions thank you so
this committee has resolved to
de fer for the reasons given and I
really am looking forward to this coming
back a much much much better application
than the one we see before us otherwise
we could well refuse it again and that
would be boring
right okay so we are moving forward on
the agenda
okay slowly to item 1802 641 the firs
Garden Grove Road stratford-upon-avon
and if we can ask we'll do this and then
probably yeah Charlotte Dix to run us
through that piece
Thank You chairman this item indicated
on the map by the black circle the
application site is located on the
western side of the town center and it's
within the built-up area boundary a
conservation area of stratford-upon-avon
this slide shows the application site as
a red circle located towards the bottom
of the slide the site has only
pedestrian access due to its position
within the first garden a public park
the red buildings and railings visible
on the plan are listed buildings whilst
the pink line which is visible on the
left-hand side of the photo denotes the
edge of the conservation area the three
green circles indicate trees which
benefit from a tree preservation order
this is an application for full planning
permission for a Chinese peony pavilion
this slide shows the proposed block plan
showing the location of the pavilion in
relation to the nearest trees on the
site the plan on the right-hand side of
screen is a zoomed in version of the
same plan this slide shows the proposed
North elevation of the pavilion on the
left-hand side this elevation would be
replicated when we eat from the southern
side the pavilion is of traditional
Chinese design and would measure six
point five meters in total height the
floor plan on the right-hand side of the
screen shows that the pavilion would
feature six sides and would have a
footprint of approximately 11 square
meters this photo shows the view of the
application site from chestnut walk
facing west the site is indicated by the
yellow arrow this photo is taken moving
further along chestnut walk almost at
the junction with robber Street first
garden and the application site were
visible more closely but the properties
on engrave Road visible in the
background this photo is taken from the
south east of the application site with
was rather Street in the foreground
looking north three firs garden the
junction with chestnut walk is visible
on the right-hand side of the photo and
part of Grove Road can be seen on the
left hand
I'd the approximate sighting of the
Pavillion is shown by the yellow RA the
screening which would be provided by
soft landscaping in suggested condition
three would limit views from the south
this photo is taken from the southwest
of the application site facing north
along Grove Road the southern part of
first garden is visible essentially
within the photo and the approximate
location of the pavilion is shown by the
yellow arrow again this photo is taken
from within first garden close to where
the police station is located this photo
is taken facing south towards the
application site which is again
indicated by the yellow arrow in the
background this photo is taken from
rodder streets facing south
this photo is again taken from brother
Street facing across towards Grove Road
the approximate location of the pavilion
is shown by the yellow arrow the two
pedestrian entrances twofers garden
which are visible are those noted within
suggested condition for which are
proposed to be closed just to clarify
there are updates within the update
sheet please also note that there dates
of the no objection comments from county
highways on page 37 of the agenda should
we 23rd of November 2018
instead of 23rd of October officer
recommendation is to grant full planning
permission subject the conditions found
on pages 45 and 46 of the agenda and the
additional condition within the update
sheet thank you thank you very much
Charlotte we do have any updates on this
have people read the update sheet on
this
so we don't have any representation for
the Town Council on this so if we can go
to the speakers and objectives we have
two objectives I think who have
registered to speak this evening Thomas
Baxter and Simon savage who are
Stratford residents they have three
minutes between them you're welcome to
come up sit together or on separate
tables and you will have one and a half
minutes each and so I was looking over
there mr. Savage
have a seat do we have from mr. Baxter
ah okay good
so mr. Savage you happy to speak first
one and a half minutes okay yeah The
Mail on Sunday a connect conducting a
national survey to protect parks and
open spaces which is what this is a
conservation area
I bought my house in April in August
last year just across the road from
where this is proposed and I don't
object to the construction at all but is
what I'm here to say in August last year
I saw the Chinese delegation in the park
with the local councilors looking at
this park and taking photographs I would
approach them it was pouring with rain
three weeks later I see in the paper
that this is what's being proposed now
this was the first of any of us knew in
the location that this was going to take
place I feel it's being rushed through
because of Shakespeare's birthday
celebrations coming up in April now I've
got three suggestions for this place the
first in southern Lane there's been a
tree taken down in the Shakespeare
garden snow they would have to be
approached ideal place to put it
it wouldn't it's an open space there
where you've got to replace the that
tree the second place is a Content
Vernie at the Arts and Cultural Center
if they were approached they've already
got a Chinese porcelain collector
there and it would be an ideal location
if they were approached for it to be put
in the grounds there which I know very
well it could be sympathetically
landscaped and it would look fine
sitting there now the third place the
ten seconds sorry 10 second is well the
third place is on the gyratory this has
already been turned down because of the
manmade agency said about flooding but
that unit could be put on floatation
units with cantilever arms on it's
similar to static homes as the caravans
there must be 500 static homes on the a
van in the floodplain and if it was
looked at properly it could be put on
that sort of footing okay thank you very
much mm-hmm are there any questions
which we do questions half-and-half any
questions for mr. Savage no okay mr.
Baxter if you press the button on the
face that's it good thank you right in
1910 as you all know Marie Corelli
purchased the site and lease it or gave
it to the townspeople so that we could
walk around and relax
it's what's happened to that objective
this is going to be a building it's
going to be up to six meters high and
three meters across and coming from an
environment cultural environment Farnese
that is so foreign to here it's going to
stand out like a sore thumb and what
does the planning people say very good
it all harmonized in fact one of the
officers actually says it's going to
pavilion will be comparable to a band
and so enhancing the existing use of the
gardens My heavens
this is taking everything into a totally
different ballpark and it's gonna pull
in tourism that's what they say
so again the motivating factor here is
Maddie it's all about environment
it's not about culture or history or
anything like that all that's been
totally ignored thank you very much
mm-hmm any questions for mr. Baxter
councillor Jones what I notice about
this piece of green space is that it
could perhaps do with a little bit more
use in life because in a way it sits in
this road junction now it's almost I
feel gets a bit overlooked do you think
there is the opportunity if there is
something in there for it to become kind
of better used for it to reinvigorate
the purpose of the area
my personal view councilor is that it
should be left just as it is so that
people can relax in their own different
ways it doesn't we're not always we get
the set all the time with a word
development change and all that sort of
stuff we don't have to do that all the
time in any concert on any job or
anything like that so keep everything as
it is so that people can go in there in
their different ways and just exist in
their different ways okay thank you very
much no other questions if you'd like to
press that button and return to your
seats
appreciate it and we will now hear from
the supporters and applicants we have a
lot of people here you can all come
forward if you want we have Liz
Nicholson welcome back
Terry perks councillor Jefferson good
evening
Ketel lovely mr. team ding good evening
sir please as many as you can come
forward and take your seats you have
presumably figured out how you're going
to use your three minutes and who will
be speaking can you just maybe describe
him mister mr. Diaz and why he will be
taking technical questions mr. ding as a
representative of the city of Fujio
I was based in London's come here to
provide further details that the
committee had any questions about the
background to the project they've
initiated ok thank you
so your 3 minutes begins it's a little
more than three minutes
thank you it's worth setting the context
to this planning application
stratford-upon-avon has an international
reputation thanks to William Shakespeare
the district attracts some 6.2 million
visitors a year
that reputation means the town has many
links worldwide latest and close links
with it with China civic visits diffuser
started in December 2015
2018 we received an award which our
Chairman collected on our behalf in
Wuhan the award was from the Chinese
international cities Association last
year thanks to his visit to Fuzhou
on the development of the Sun wind
project as well as the award
stratford-upon-avon received significant
press coverage in the FT The Times Daily
Telegraph Daily Mail independent in the
UK South China Morning Post and Tsing
hua we truly have international standing
the NPP F is clear that economic
sustainability is a key consideration in
planning decisions I quote
an economic objective to help build a
strong responsive and competitive
economy
I would also reflect it is not unusual
for the town to receive gifts town
library and American Fountain were both
gifts to return to the economic
sustainability point tourism is the
second biggest industry in the district
it's estimated to generate 409 million
in revenue and employs seven thousand
six hundred people he is one of the
engines of our prosperity the
International significance of Stratford
is a marketing opportunity for the
region as a whole has not gone unnoticed
by the CW LED or the WMCA some may say
that a Chinese pagoda was out of place
in the first garden which is considered
to be a place for reflection we
considered a number of potential
locations for the pakoda including the
Bancroft gardens recreation ground a
number of traffic islands and sights
further out of town having considered
the constraints on these sites we
settled on the first garden as our
preferred location in my view the pagoda
will be an interesting structure which
will enhance this space there's a long
history of such interesting structures
in the UK usually termed Follies
described as an ornamental structure
often times strange fantastical or
whimsical it will be an asset to the
first garden and the town the generous
gift of the pagoda is a clear statement
of the warm relationships and cultural
exchange with our Chinese friends 30
seconds Stratford has an international
reputation and this gift can only
reinforce it in conclusion the NPP f
states that there should be a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development this planning application
clearly meets this criterion thank you
very well done on the three minutes
thank you any questions
councillor Perry thank you good evening
Council Jefferson I just wonder whether
you can advise if if
or what level of consultation has been
undertaken with the neighboring with
with the neighboring areas when you
looked at all the sites that you were
looking looking at we haven't done any
formal consultation with the the
neighbor sort of prior to putting in the
planning application I reviewed a number
of sites with councilor organist the
portfolio of the councillors lands and
we were trained a number to find the
ones that were the most suitable
appraised their constraints we did some
releases in the through the chapel
Herald and the Preston on our website to
make people aware of it and then the
public consultation was part of what's
been done as part of the planning
process
okay so Giles does every single house
and person who owns a property that is
has a view of this know that it might be
happening
sorry Freda now there's another message
thank you I mean it's maybe enough
question more for your officers but they
will have carried out the statutory
consultation with the site like this
it's most likely they put a site notice
up if it's in conservation area that
they'll have been a press-up for as well
it's a better way of doing it than
letters to every single individual
property and also there isn't a direct
effect in the same way as and there's an
extension on a house next door to
somebody's house you know you could you
can't you wouldn't send letters to every
single house why'd you stop I suppose
okay thank you
that's probably a question for the
officers later as well councillor Barnes
on the bike as you know there's no
impediment for any of the trees on a rep
unit or where it's going because there
is no space in the middle it could go
but my concern
you know some one thing yeah we
submitted a free report so in
agriculturalists as looked at the site
there is one tree where it goes slightly
into the root protection area but with
proper tree for section measures
construction won't be a problem and
having in place there after it doesn't
affect the tree canopies and it won't
affect the roots of the trees so you've
had that from another culturist as part
of the report I [ __ ] answer the wood
we can ask that as a technical question
because we have had some comments from
the public on that can select concern
thanks Jalen I must just say the lack of
consultation with neighbors is to be
regretted you know hear the explanation
but this is something which is very
welcome and it's very good that we've
had this and we ought to make the most
of it
what I cannot understand is the comment
about the constraints of the Bancroft
gardens that is the focus of all our
tourism and therefore in my opinion we
are missing out by locating it where it
is because it is not in the core of the
tourist attraction we don't get the
advantage for me if you'd like to answer
that yes yeah I think the the main issue
you have when you look at some of those
sites is the flood zone the problem is
if you go to the Bancroft or think sites
who looked out close to the gyratory
you're in the flood zone which is a real
you know there's serious restrictions
then on what you can do
you also have grade 1 listed buildings
grade 2 stylistic buildings and whilst
that isn't an insurmountable problem
that is a key planning issue for you ok
again that's something we could
potentially I'm so sorry I do not want
to have to ask people to leave but I
will I would rather you were able to
watch the proceedings but I will ask
people to leave if they don't respect
how we run this which is not to hear
shout it out from the audience only for
those who were speaking Thank You
counselor Giles I wonder with reference
to the diagram of the pavilion if I
could just get a better idea of what the
materials are I don't have a good idea
about what the color is what the nature
of the materials are on each part of the
structure thank you
thank you the structure is essentially
formed from timber it would be
traditionally should have timber wood it
would be pay a hand-painted finish by
Chinese craftsmen who will be sent over
confuse you it'd be a sort of a deep red
color and I think one of the conditions
requires us to and provide details of
the four details of the paint scheme
practice of implementing the timber
elements of the building it's got a sort
of pan tiled roof and a timber columns
and timber lattice work with the stone
plinth pan type do you say pan tiled oh
it's like a tile like like yes like a
shaped roof tile that formed that
Scarlets okay any other questions No
thank you very much for I'm afraid we
should no no we're not gonna make any
exceptions for that for the council
sorry so thank you very much and you may
retire and now we are open to questions
to the officers oh I'm terribly sorry
counselor please
we have a lot of this just whatever yes
and you have five minutes I think so
thank you very much if I'd like to get
back to some planning reasons I'm very
sorry
it's what I have five minutes as what
cancel yeah thinking I'm very sorry to
be here objecting to the sighting of
this gift from China in retrospect it
would have been a good idea to abort all
counselors were Stratford together as
soon as this gift had been accepted
sometime in 2018 to understand the
nature of the gift and propose an
appropriate site a pre-application
presentation would have engaged
counselors and residents I understand
that there are time restraints as SDC
want the pavilion in place for the
birthday celebrations in April however I
do have objections safety is an issue
this position has indicated it's close
to the apex of the garden high highly
visible at this busy entrance to the
town it is in close proximity to
junction just that walk for the street
Grove Road this Junction is very busy
and as has a higher level of accidents
and other junctions in the town the
pavilion in this position will have
impact on drivers concentration which
weren't may well contribute to further
difficulties here I am concerned that
highways alter their original objection
their first mitigation was a
recommendation to move the pavilion
further into the firs this objection was
changed to no objection provide certain
conditions were Adair - I am speechless
at highways proposing conditions of
closing the south entrance to chestnut
walk preventing residents using their
historic much-used passage from town to
home and vice versa choice walking from
Anne Hathaway's cottage from the town
center to Anne Hathaway's cottage we'll
want to visit the pavilion on their way
and there is no safe crossing to the
firs here presumably visitors to the
site will just jump over the wall that's
being blocked up will this be the case
for Chinese dignitaries well maybe hope
to visit that and see their gift I am
sure local guided walks will want to
include the pavilion
right Henry Isis twice there are no
crossings to the furs I find it equally
disturbing to read that extra screening
should be planted on the south side of
the furs this will completely alter the
open aspect of this little garden and
provide cover for the occasional
antisocial behavior often reported here
planting was removed from the Bancroft
some years ago to suppress anti-social
behavior I believe that this planting
would be contrary to neighborhood
development plan b e for designing out
crime this states at proposals which
failed to satisfactorily create a safe
and secure environment will not be
supported I completely disagree with the
highways proposal and have told them so
local residents are very concerned that
any structure should be placed here at
all this land was given to the town as a
quiet place by Mary Corelli
and a gift is clearly stated all
noticeboard in the garden she bought the
firs in 1910 to preserve an open space
for the benefit of the town
the NDP policy CLW 1 protecting and
enhancing community facilities residents
consider the first gift to the community
and is a community facility which is in
active use with all paths in constant
news and it's and they don't believe it
should become a tourist attraction I
have concerns about the excavation for
concrete foundations here among highly
rated area and the cutting back of
branches to give space mark Hicks and
advisor on tree issues has asked
technical questions of SDC as to the
merchants of the area of route
preservation specified in the tree
survey he considers the proximity of
road hard road surfaces has not been
taken into account and thinks the trees
will be placed under more pressure than
crated finally there are the rightful
ambitions but the pavilion to become a
tourist attraction
adding economic vibrancy to the town but
this is a small somewhat secluded area
on the edge of the town center where
there are no pedestrian crossings to the
site nearest control crossing if access
by continuous pavement is at the town
centre crossroads roller Street and
grove road north road there is no place
for a brief coach stop for a photo op
there are far better sites in the town
for this prestigious gift
there are NDP
policies which enable you to reject this
application I ask you to vote against
this most unsuitable site not the
Pavillion not voting against that and
call a meeting destructed cancers
immediately to an agree a best site for
this gift thank you any questions cash
for club right mr. chairman thank you
overall this question is apologies in
advance
can I ask why the Town Council didn't
make any representations on this place
okay I'm here as a district councillor
representing my ward I'm not here to
represent the town I think that's an
adequate answer caster bounce
I believe the mock show that Calipari
council freshly so am i right in
thinking you were not consulted at all
on this particular site by any fellow
councillors looking at this is can you
tell me when the first time you heard
that this was the designated site for
the for this beautiful I have to say
beautiful gift
I completely agree this beautiful gift
my first knowledge of it was when it
came through the planning process okay
no more questions thank you very much
counselor now we can go to technical
questions anybody came to Giles
is the closing up of the pedestrian
entrances at the south end of the firs
Gardens crucial to grant in other words
if we were to get rid of that condition
would that mean that actually then the
Highway Authority would have a problem
the highways authority have removed
their objection based on the suggested
conditions which were including the
screening provided to the south of the
pavilion and the closing up of those two
entrances on Sirah the streets and Grove
Road could you just show me on the map
just I'm pretty sure I know which
entrances are you're talking about but
yeah it's this entrance here where our
path terminates and this entrance over
here that there are three other
entrances which would remain these three
here the update report talks about since
the report was written additional tree
information has been received and it's
clear that this impact on the trees in
the vicinity will be greater than
originally expected I just wondered if
you could expand a little bit because if
we're going to balance it up I think we
need to know what is the degree of risk
to any tree on that site
and an objection has been received since
we received the the tree survey which
raises concerns in terms of the way the
tree survey has been conducted in terms
of the RPA of t4 which is this you tree
here the RP a does the RPI and the trees
are ready to show that there was a three
to four percent incursion which would be
as a result of the pavilion
however the objector has raised the
point that the pathway along brother
Street and the highway on this section
of the road would actually incur into
the RP a as it is so normally because of
existing site conditions the RP a would
be increased on the opposite side so it
would be expected that the RPI would
actually be increased on this side of
the tree I know we have other questions
but on that why can it not be moved
slightly can it be moved slightly
because there seems to be plenty of
space for it outside any you know RP a
which which was took account of that
could they do that within this
application this diagram does not
actually show the RPAs of the trees this
is showing the existing tree locations
that we have to deal with the
application that's in front of us and
the siting of the that Pavilion is
dictated by the site the redline site
plan which was to Missa with the
application okay
Richards I was going to ask about the
two entrances that were closing
you've asked answer to my first part the
question the second will be if highways
object we are entitled to ignore the
mommy
he looked panicked I apologize
chairman the the look of panic wasn't to
look a panic
we were we were simply considering
whether to give a detailed answer or to
say yes and I think the correct answer
in this instance is yes okay thank you
and have we got any indication as to
what the screening is going to be and
roughly where
we haven't got the details at this stage
which is why it is suggested condition
number three so we've asked for those
details to be submitted so we can ensure
that it does provide the correct
screening in line with what County
highways requires yeah I saw the
condition okay can tracking some German
it was stated by the supporters one of
them that the Bancroft garden is flood
risk area it is I know it has been
funded when was it last flooded what
alleviation action has been taken to
avoid that and you know in the future
and is the type of structure so
vulnerable to any water egress that it
would create enormous damage I know it I
decide to scale but if you can give a
brief if I can answer this question in
reverse chair there are two aspects to
to flood risk one is the susceptibility
of the structure to flooding and the
other is the impact of the structure on
flooding elsewhere so it is reasonable
to assume that this structure would not
be susceptible to flooding no one would
be harmed if this structure was flooded
but it would equally have an impact on
flooding elsewhere because it's built
above ground it would have a consequence
and it would be normal for the
Environment Agency to object to that
having said all of that this of course
isn't part of this application it's not
something members can take into account
for this application because there is no
flooding issue with this application
councillor Perry Thank You chair as this
application is positioned as a tourist
opportunity can the officers advise
where the nearest parking area would be
for a coach
or yes where-where-where wood coaches
stop for people on board to get off to
go and have a look at the pagoda what
you have in front of you here is a
proposal to build a tourist attraction
it's a pavilion as with much of the rest
of Stratford no doubt the tourists who
visit will visit this pavilion there are
bus parking spaces and car parking
spaces further along rather streets
kakera birds can't cancel highways or
conditions
I read the conditions the two conditions
that can't see how highways have
requested are the ones relating to
screening and the closing approved
they're pedestrian entrances so that's
condition number three and condition
number four okay thank you councillor
Giles I'm just about the consultation
point so if you could just tell me what
sort of consultation has taken place in
relation to this planning application
and whether there was any pre
application consultation no
pre-application consultation was carried
out in terms of consultation for the
planning application all of the
statutory consultation was carried out
direct neighbor letters were sent in the
post out to adjoining properties in
quite a wide area around the proposed
site and also a site notice was erected
on the site and also a press advert was
put in the paper okay can we go to the
debate
you want a question did you want a
question you just want to follow up I
wasn't told when it was last flooded at
Bancroft on what I think it's relevant
to this to this I'm sorry can so we're
not going to go there we're gonna go to
debate councillor Giles I think the
first thing to be said is it's it's so
lovely that mr. ding has come tonight
and it's just a real honor
it's an enormous ly kind gift from
future the idea that you'll go we're
going to have people from that area who
are going to come and decorate this is a
real honor it's certainly the first
opportunities that you know I've had to
express that and I think it's an utterly
wonderful thing and I think anything
that we do to continue our links and our
friendship is magnificent and I think
that what makes it important is that we
get this in the right place because it's
um it is something people want to see
and it's something that we want to hold
in the highest of respect in terms of
this location I I'm in something of a
dilemma in some respects this is
actually really it's just around the
corner from the border of my ward
it is a difficult location in a way it's
a part of Stratford which is you know
the garden here is is underused in my
view because it's sitting in this very
very busy road sort of Apex is very
difficult to cross here there's
certainly no parking or waiting it's I
think it's a problematic area for
Stratford so on one hand you could argue
that to add something here may enhance
the area and increase its its use and
its vibrancy on the other hand you could
argue it's not giving due prominence to
such a wonderful gift I have to say I
think there are some specific problems
that do concern me I think the closing
of those two particular and entrances is
a major issue actually they are the
crossing points here are very very
difficult and actually all that will
happen is it's a low wall people will
just jump over that wall because they
want to get from A to B in the quickest
way it's just not not what we want it's
not safe it's not desirable there's no
point
you know paths and entrances are
designed in a way that's user friendly
and as soon as you block it off people
just take their own path to avoid it and
I do have concerns about that I also do
have concern about route protection
normally I would say well you know maybe
we're being overcautious but the
difficulty here is because because what
I've said about this area is is the case
and that actually this garden is so
important in terms of bringing some life
and nature to this area you know we've
seen that those barriers their road
safety barriers they're necessary for
road safety but they're ugly we have two
traffic light junctions which are
necessary but ugly and the trees there
are so crucial for providing a sense of
you know greenery and space and I and I
think mr. Baxter has got a point about
actually do we always want to do
something to somewhere I am mindful of
the fact that there is a lot of business
along here all of these places a
bed-and-breakfast their views are
incredibly important about how what they
think about happens you know to this
area and is it right for their area and
I am very concerned that there is no
pre-application consultation I have to
say that baffles me this is around the
corner from my ward and I didn't know it
was going here until I saw this planning
application I mean how can it that is
slightly strange I am however pleased to
see that some letters were sent and I
think that's very positive but it does
make me sort of think this is such a
special gift why have we lost the
opportunity really I'm sure lots of
thought has been given to siting and
where it may or may not go and it may
well be that this is possibly a good
place but it does concern me that we
haven't really had that as a group of of
councillors and particularly locally
interested people haven't had that
opportunity to really input into where
is the best and most desirable place for
this so if I'm honest I'm you know I'm
sort of weighing it up because I think
it could reinvigorate the area but I
have concerns and I want I want it to be
right so I if I'm honest I'm urging
towards refusal but not because I don't
think it's a lovely thing it's just
about getting it absolutely right but
I'm very interested to hear what the
rest
committee has to say okay Cass
Chancellor Perry I know I'm sorry that
where we have heard it thank you okay
Thank You chair I actually have to agree
with my learned friend on my right-hand
side I do say I concur with everything
she said I think it's the most wonderful
gift but I've got a big question mark
I'm afraid in terms of the siting I feel
something like that you need to be
seeing it also from a distance to really
appreciate the beauty and the splendor
it's not having been to China myself not
not in this particular area but I have
been to Beijing I've been to Shanghai
and I have seen the most beautiful
buildings that a lot of them are most
appreciated from standing back and
viewing it and I just I just feel my
other concern is about the consultation
I think this is this having it there we
want Stratford to feel they have a sense
of belonging towards this and really
fully appreciate the very special
relationship that Stratford is
developing with China and and I just
feel greater consultation with more
people particularly also residents
because at the end of the day you know
it is just it just it it that space has
been identified because that that looked
like a sort of one of the Gateway
entrances into the town coming from the
evesham road but I just feel perhaps
greater a longer process and greater
public consultation and also we
counselors because I think we want
Stratfor Tian's to really take ownership
of this and be very proud of it and I
just I just think it's beautiful but
perhaps it's just in being proposed in
the wrong place and it is with great
regret that I shall be refusing because
I feel it's just out of character being
pushed into that area where we currently
have an open green space of reflective
space but also there is a Medical Center
sort of opposite that side of things and
I know people use the paths to go from
rather street down into Grove Road so
I'm afraid there are too many things
against it so it is with regret because
I think it's a beautiful building I just
think it needs to be cited so people can
see it from a lot of different angles
and from a sense of space so I will be
refusing I'm Tara so if we can get a
counter to Richards I missed you mate
yet so before I start I would echo what
Casa Jaya said it is a privilege that
has been bestowed on us by the Chinese
delegate to have this this fabulous gift
we should be very proud of the
relationships that have been forged with
the Chinese and with other areas of the
world as well and we should make the
most of that looking at this planning
application and I would remind them as
we are looking at planning application
we're not looking at the rights or
wrongs of this site over other sites
that is a decision for cabinets make on
Monday with any I understand it is an
item coming forward to the cabinet on
Monday
we're looking at the planning merits of
this site again I would agree with
councillor jars I with the entrances and
exits to the two footpaths and I have
reservations over that and my view was
that actually
/ because we know we can there's still a
path there there is a path that goes
around the outside so there are still
the facility to walk around fairly
quickly
that's a roadside path but it makes more
sense to maintain once they're done
right I think there's it with the
screening done right I think there was a
potential for this to be really quite a
pleasant tranquil area yeah she blocks
away a lot of the road which at the
moment is a really rather grim area
would block way along the road make it
quite a pleasant place to sit and
contemplate and just be I think as one
of our speakers mentioned but we just
have no detail over what that screening
is likely to be and without that I'm
funny very difficult to make an informed
an appropriate decision I can understand
how it could be fabulous but I can also
see right now how it couldn't could not
be fabulous I wonder whether it's worth
deferring to get more information on
that and we can then debate and discuss
further if it's not possible to do that
then I am struggling a little bit to
support as much as I would really like
to I'm struggling without that
information okay can start concern I
reflected what my colleagues have said
actually and as far as planning issues
America need be concerned you know it's
a bit relevant I think in the handout
we've had that there is some comment
here clear that the impact of the trees
in the facility will be greater than
originally expected you know that's
quite an admission without any doubt
again there's no consideration about
residents loss of quiet enjoyment that I
believe is a planning issue which should
be acknowledged to me other factors have
been well explained by my colleagues but
in short summary the location to me for
something of this value to us which we
can boast about internationally the
proposed location is a bit of an insult
like a councillor Bob's beautiful thing
in between a lot of trees which really
would like stone
the people to look at the only people
are actually going to look at it the
people stuck on the road waiting to get
to the bearing abode laughs as you might
but so I damned the reason for refusal
well I think I'll come in here as cash
the Richards rightly said we are
deciding this application it's up to the
cabinet where they eventually decide to
put it we have to decide what's before
us not what we would like to be
somewhere else so you've got to decide
this application anoint your preference
for location
personally I my main concerns as well as
the the entrances I would certainly take
that out as a condition I wouldn't I
would not support this with the
condition to block up the entrances I
think I should say so I wouldn't want
that but apart from that I'm quite happy
for our offices to make the decision on
what is a good screening to enhance that
area I mean that that's their job anyway
so removing the the blocking up of the
walls I think I would support this I
can't I can't I know this garden it is a
place for reflection it is a lovely
place to sit for local people having
your lunch break I mean that's where I I
go anyway and this is a physical barrier
to to what's behind it I think just just
that aspect if it is positive is
positive
whatever it was it happens to be this
dis fantastic gift representing
friendship between two places and
cultures which i think is another
addition to this location and are
completely completely
appropriate one for a place of
contemplation and a place of that was
purchased you know through literary
endeavor and in Stratford town yes it
may be better on the top of a hill
somewhere to be more appreciated but I
think this is a suitable place for it to
be appreciated
so I would be proposing that we go with
the offer
officer recommendations on this with the
exception of blocking the blocking the M
the wall up yeah and condition for so
with the exception of condition for I am
proposing that we accept the officer
recommendation and grant so I'd been
looking for a second or a second I'd be
happy to second if I had a better
understanding of what this landscaping
plan was going to be if it's just a few
small shrubs it's a complete waste of
time if it's some reasonably Pleasant
bushes or trees or something that's a
little bit higher makes it a little bit
more enclosed and for people to actually
go in and sit and become fluent and
enjoy the tranquility of that what if
you want to do that through there
through the chair I'm sure we can do
that we can do that in consultation with
the chair traffic you need some
landscaping you block a lot of that
noise and anyways you made the point
earlier that it's mostly stationary
along there so so so councillor Richards
we can do that we can vote on it if you
want a second it with the that
particular condition condition three
approved by the chair and I can consult
with local members on that and the
committee
I think I want to see it if I'm honest
I'm not comfortable seconding something
where I haven't seen the detail off
I think the detail if this is it's
particularly portent giving it a given
its central location in town and the
importance of this thing okay
counterproposal to defer and so we've
got that information so we can make it
fully an informed decision well I
couldn't find a second so that Falls
we've got a a proposer to defer molly
would you like to say anything
councillor John suppose council Richard
is entitled to see whether anyone will
second his proposal because my proposal
would be to refuse it
okay anyone wish to second a proposal to
defer on the grounds of looking at the
landscaping condition councillor Crump
okay all those in favor of deferring the
application to consider the landscaping
condition all those against three let's
start this again sorry we're going to do
this again oh no what was happening
there well we would have done if people
that have been old if people continue to
be asleep so we're started again all
those in favor of deferring the
application in favor of deferring the
application all those against deferring
all those abstaining casting vote as the
chairman I vote that we defer
there we go right um we're gonna we're
going to move back to the first we're
going to go back to the first item so
cancel Giles we're also going to have a
break so we're going to get back here at
5:00 to 8:00
okay committee I propose that we deal
with application 17 / 0 1 847
stroked-out
and if I could ask the Miss cosmic to
present the case thank you
Thank You chair so it's not a planning
application per se committee resolved to
grant the commercial development of
redditch gateway last January subject to
a note requiring formation of a steering
group to facilitate engagement around
the design of buildings and the HTV
routing strategy there are two elements
and therefore two recommendations to
item 4 of your agenda the first element
of item 4 relates to the membership of
the Redditch gateway steering group the
current membership are set out in the
terms of reference is detailed on pages
8 & 9 of your agenda chair the
recommendation is to allow Warwickshire
County Council of records and
Worcestershire county councillor Baker
price to become additional members of
the steering group as detailed in the
committee report thank you
there's Planning Committee how many
questions for the officer um I think I'd
like to ask a question I just want to
know what I have to say I don't and some
waters caused this to come to committee
is it that the committee have not been
able to agree themselves the membership
we as you know I agree through you as
vice-chair the makeup of the steering
group which also include the members
we've had three steering group meetings
and they've gone fine and progressed at
the second steering group meeting
councilor Ricard's came as Warwickshire
County Council for sturdily and it was
decided that it should come back as a
decision for committee to determine the
membership who's already quite large
given the cross boundary nature of the
application so it was something which we
wanted to get a bit of feedback from
committee as the party who wanted the
steering group formulated in the first
place to ensure that you were happy with
a slight expansion of the group given
that they they are essentially an
interested party in the site um and
there's any other questions I propose to
open the matter for debate I have a
comment but I'm happy to
from anyone else first I um it comes
with sorry counts bronze didn't see
either we've had this before we agreed
to bring it back the steering group has
come up with the suggestions which are
appropriate on quality were proven yes I
would comment that actually the setting
up of the steering group was a specific
response actually to resident concern
that they wanted to have detailed input
on a site which is going to have any
magnificent impact arguably both
positive but also negative on the area
for some people and I have to say I
appreciate there's a need to keep
certain groups proportionate and it is a
rather big membership but I think what
of more of overriding importance is that
everybody who feels they ought to have a
say in relation to a very important
development ought to be there to have a
say so I have to say I certainly would
propose that we amended the steering
group membership to allow both councilor
rickards and counts of the Baker price
to sit on it if they wish to do so don't
know whether anyone wants a second Molly
as a county councillor as well as the
District Council that I would totally
support that move and would be delighted
to second your proposal thank you we
have a proposal to well I suppose it's
not really grant but it confirmed agree
and confirm the recommendation that the
committee amend the steering group to
include the two named counts so there's
all those in favor
thank you we resolved to confirm that
recommendation
okay so that was just a bit about
Redditch gateway specifically I had to
sit out on or wished to sit out on so
and see if we can go to the next bit
Thank You chairman
the second element of item four relates
to the guidelines for the operation of
steering groups more generally chair the
recommendation is that the guidelines
for the operation of steering groups as
detailed on page 11 of the agenda are
endorsed thank you okay what page are
they actually on the agenda all right of
course it's at the front yeah
are there any comments and this I was
happy when they read them councillor
Giles yes sir I've got a comment
actually I would personally in the first
bullet point like to remove the words
only and absolutely so I would like it
and prefer it to read planning
committees are asked to established in
groups where necessary I'm you know I
understand and I think it's important
that it sets out the groups of
time-consuming I agree about the minutes
and actually notes of decisions is is
there but the reality is we set up the
ability to have steering groups in
response to huge amounts of ongoing
resident concern about their ability to
input on highly detailed applications
the detail of which is often beyond a
planning committee to really get under
the skin of and these these groups are
absolutely crucial in being able to
determine the course of these these
major planning applications which have
an impact on the district for
generations to come
so I have to say I personally find that
was the first sentence to be too
restrictive I understand the principle
of basically saying we shouldn't be just
granting on every single application
willy nilly but that's personally the
amendment I would would want to support
I'm quite happy with the wording but as
a mascot any comments on that
on what Molly's said no well okay so I'm
happy with the wording I would propose I
hear what you're saying but I'm I'm
happy with absolutely necessary having
sat on one of them now they do take a
long time
and and I think we should only do
someone we absolutely have to so I
absolutely recommend endorsing agreeing
these these guidelines do I have a
seconder now we've got a committee of
twenty three I believe you know
consequently minutes of the steering
group meetings will not be taken I do
find that odd that we cannot have any
captured information about a group which
is claimed to be so important you were
to come back on that because it's there
will be at the main of a minute but
there is information I think it's more
to sort of minimize the admin pressure
on the case officer to document
everything as formally as we would do
with a formal planning committee meeting
that doesn't mean today we wouldn't take
notes and obviously the key thing with
these sorts of groups is to make sure
that everyone understands the actions
which come from them so that we're
achieving what we want to through the
groups and so it's not to say there
won't be detailed notes but I think it's
just not so much of the laboriousness
that comes with doing four more minutes
so I'm so happy to recommend that the
committee goes with this and I I have
the second all those in favor of
accepting all those against
okay so we've resolved to accept those
thank you very much and now we are
moving on to the next agenda item
somebody can remind me where we are
okay great
yes application 1802 three nine three
Kingsmead farm Stratford Road Wales born
and a me to inform us about that
Thank You chairman the application site
donated by the black dot is known as
Kingsmead farm an early 18th century
traditional farmhouse with an extensive
range of 19th century outbuildings
groups around two courtyards the site is
located to the south of child Kerr in an
open countryside location approximately
1.5 miles from Wales born the site Edge
red founds the grounds of child cut Park
a grade two star registered Historic
Park which is situated the north and
adjoins but is not in chocolate and
Hampton Lucy's Conservation Area the
site is accessed by an existing access
to the west and the previous access of
Stratford Road has been blocked up
following planning permission the
nearest neighboring property is copper
heath to the southeast which has a
separate access planning permission is
sought for seven dwellings this is a
resubmission with some amendments made
to the design of application 17-0 double
to 0-3 full which was refused by West
Planning Committee on the 26th of July
2018 the site has an extensive planning
history building 7 8 & 9
has an extent permission to convert from
from free holiday lights into free
residential units in addition another
example mission exists for building 7 &
8 for extensions and buildings 2 to 6
have permission for 5 holiday let's the
existing and proposed site plan shows
the extent of the proposed development
extensions are proposed to the north of
building 7 & 8 edge yellow and green on
the plan for the proposed site plan and
building 9 would be converted in
addition to elevational changes to
create three dwellings buildings two to
six edge red seats remove holiday light
restrictions and reconfigure the
accommodation including external
alterations to create free dwellings
building one edged blue is proposed to
be converted into one dwelling building
11 would be converted into garages and
in addition to 2
garage blocks to be built which are
edged purple building seven proposes a
two-story rear extension and other
internal external alterations to create
a full bedroom dwelling known as plot
five building seven eight and nine
proposes a two-story rear extension the
extension and other internal external
alterations to create two free bedroom
dwellings known as plot six and seven
and a detached garage is also proposed
to serve both of these plots which you
can't see on this planets on the
previous plan which I can show you at
the end if you meet you
the proposed elevations were plots five
six and seven are now being shown the
extensions would introduce extensive
areas of cladding and large areas of
glazing
please note that the floor plan show two
windows on the floor projecting gable on
the South elevation which have not been
drawn on the proposed elevations just
here across building two six it is
proposed to remove holiday let
restrictions and internal external
reconfiguration and alterations are
proposed to create a one four bedroom
dwelling plot four and two two-bedroom
dwellings which will be known as plot
five and six it is proposed to convert
building one into one four-bedroom
dwelling a detached garage is also
proposed to serve plot one so the
proposed elevations plot one to four are
now being shown and this slide is
showing the proposed garages for plot
one at the top and plots six and seven
is a double garage so these elevations
compare the proposed North and South
elevations of this application and
building six seven and eight against the
extant permissions which are across the
site so if you work down existing
elevations were at the top and then
followed by two extant permissions the
second from the bottom is the
application which was was that committee
last July and then the application at
the bottom is for the
proposal this at this slide sorry shows
proposed floor plans for building six
seven and eight and again comparing the
current application against the extent
permissions so the slide now being shown
compares the proposed elevations of the
previous application determined last
year against the current proposal for
building seven to nine these circles
identify areas of change so you can see
at the top we have lost a forward
projecting extension which would have
previously served barraging through an
alternative plot and this will now be
converted to formally the accommodation
for I think it was plot seven and then
if we move down to the rear the single
story extension I think it's for plot
six has been slightly increased and also
a small alteration to the reef design
and on the elevation at the bottom of
the slide the window design has been
altered to be more traditional and in
keeping with the existing elevation
again proposed elevations of the
previous application determine last year
are being shown against the current
proposal for buildings one to four in
particularly you will see that the
dormer windows have changed in their
design and also some alterations have
been made to and window openings to
retain them in more of their original
character a moving on to some images and
these images are taken from within the
courtyard of the main farmhouse range
the top image shows the South elevation
and the botted bottom image the south
and west elevations of building seven
eight and nine the top image looks in a
south easterly direction towards the
adjoining neighbor and access and the
bottom image shows the farm houses
sitting east elevation and now the
northern elevation of the farmhouse is
being shown so I can't get it in one
image so had to split it the top image
is taken looking West removing the main
farmhouse courtyard the bottom image is
taken within the second courtyard to the
self of the site and this image shows
building ones north and south elevations
and the bottom image is in view from is
its view from within its courtyard
images are now being shown of the rear
of buildings one to five and the images
are now taken within the second
courtyard the top looking in a westerly
direction towards buildings one to four
and in an easterly direction towards the
site's access and adjoining neighbor
this image is taking looking north
towards child cat park and finally the
access drive can now be seen and its
relationship with the adjoining neighbor
more clearly and building 11 can now be
seen which is proposed for garagem which
is the image at the bottom which can be
seen just in the distance on the top
image there are two updates to note on
the update sheet and chairman the
recommendation is to refuse the
application subject to the refusal
reasons as detailed have been looking at
the report thank you thank you very much
so we don't have we only have the
applicant I believe so Gary moss
Simon Butterfield
good evening I'm Gary will you be
speaking and mr. Butterfield as well and
I'll do the presentation Simon's here to
answer any questions that's lovely thank
you okay as you know it's three minutes
and I'll tell you in two and a half
thank you and as is pointed out by your
officer this is a resubmission of a
previous scheme that members may well
recall from last year primarily the
issues raised at that last meeting were
in respect of design in particular to
the former car parking area which is a
range of plot 7 which has now been
retained as is built at and effectively
retained as accommodation the other
fundamental point was being raised was
about sustainability and there was
elements there about housing mix I note
and your note from the offices report
that's pretty much has been clarified
and that matters been resolved so the
reasons for refusal has put forward are
effectively design and the concerns over
the buildings conversion and their
impact on the heritage and landscape
this is obviously very much a subjective
matter and clearly one which we disagree
with the officers report in particular
we feel that the previous schemes
although referred to offer a much worse
situation in terms of design character
in particular their projection north and
the expanse of their projection north
and to watch our car park which is key a
very sensitive area it's also in our
opinion a fairly poor pastiche design in
contrast we proposed a scheme which we
feel is far more appropriate of its time
it does respect and preserve as much of
the historic fabric as possible and any
new elements we are proposing not
clearly of a contemporary nature which
actually when you look at historic
england's design guidance and advice is
very much focused on looking at a more
contemporary feel we hope members will
agree with us on that point and just
looking back at the previous permissions
obviously there's the extent permission
which was referred to there was also
expand permissions for the farmhouse and
other alterations that were granted but
have now lapsed but effectively were
approved by this council or by the
in the past and given the policy context
has not changed fundamentally for bar
conversions that still holds some weight
in this context another key point on
that was the barn to the bottom was
originally designed to be converted into
two units which would have really
damaged the historic fabric we've
reverted that back to a single unit
retaining that open aspect I've already
covered some of the benefits of the
scheme in particular we feel the design
improvements there's also significant
landscape improvements but also we've
got a good mix of housing two three and
four beds single storey bungalows
effectively there's also greater
benefits in terms of SIL and affordable
housing payments unfortunately if we
were to implement the extent consent or
other previous consents effectively you
would not get the same level of benefits
you'd end up with a piecemeal
development which is not cohesive we
offer that and ultimately this scheme
provides a real prospect for development
as you'll see from the photographs the
scheme that's just three minutes has
been actually thank you are there any
questions
councillor krub i'm stas you mentioned
very briefly because you were in a
shorter time the reduced level of
benefits if you went back to the extant
permission just obviously if we were
implement the extent there were the
example commission that is implemented
which effectively creates free dwellings
in plots of our plot six and seven
nothing else correct that could be built
out with no requirement for any payment
the effectively the removal of the
holodeck conditions and the conversion
of the other barn wood obviously
generate potential sealants but because
there'll be less units you wouldn't get
any affordable housing money for that
and also you wouldn't necessarily get a
lot from the farmhouse itself which is
of dwelling in its own case we're
actually creating six dwellings on-site
the the farmhouse already exists
clearly oddly benefits so again you
don't get that same benefit as you would
from this code comprehensive
developments catch the bones I don't
know really we've got two three and four
screen the point being is the planners
say they're inappropriate when I look to
didn't think they were but I didn't know
whether your comments
I'm lost now to be honest
keep going Oh two three and four one of
the reasons for refusal is the comments
in the paperwork said that their active
character and I wanted whether you've
got any comments on that but we can't
find them well from our perception of my
clients perspective we would argue we've
got a very sympathetic conversion in
particular on this range and as is
reported by the officer we've got the
big threshing barn which is also at the
bottom of that range we've tried to
where possible preserve the historic
fabric in character again these have
already been converted into holiday
let's in the past so a lot of the
aesthetics are already there established
from the residential use which
historically they've always had in terms
of this range yes these were the holiday
let's so although they're currently not
viable in use effectively they were
converted into that news from a barn
okay did you know the question canister
Jo's no okay can we go back to the the
picture they brought with them the three
one on top of the other that's it okay
so presumably the top one is what's
there at the moment is it yeah and the
middle one
that's extent and the third one is what
are you're now proposing that's okay
good thank you and that's from the side
isn't it from the xylophone to the shark
up Park is sort of behind you so you're
looking effectively from shark or Park
towards a site or bit a slight angle
okay thank you no other questions No
thank you very much I'm taking it from
councillor Richards stepping up that
it's now his turn no no no no no five
minutes Thank You members what we are
considering ultimately is the
reconfiguration with minor extensions of
an existing farmhouse with associated
bonds out build and out buildings to
form a well considered and
sympathetically designed a small
community it seems to me that ultimately
there's balls down to two things one
design which is subjective and secondly
size and scale which I believe should be
considered in relation to the existing
buildings being redeveloped or extended
the development sites before 18th
century farmhouse with associated barns
and outbuildings as the officer has
rightly pointed out in her report policy
cs20 specifically allows for the
alteration modification of existing
buildings and dwellings including
proposed extensions about buildings and
annexes and indeed that policy is
further reinforced by the new MPP F
which seeks to encourage a redevelopment
of old farm buildings particularly those
in a bad state of repair into good
quality family homes the existing
buildings are already of a reasonably
significant size and therefore any
increase in shuttling size should be
considered in relation to the existing
built form we do not have a benefit of
volume or floor area increases in our
report but on judgment alone and the
pictures are using tonight one can see
that the size increase is not
significant when taken into
consideration the existing built form
and when weighing the benefit of
bringing these buildings back into a
viable use in terms of design as you as
you have seen what is being proposed has
been carefully
to fit with the existing buildings
whilst also elegantly introducing a more
modern and contemporary look to the
development for those of you who have
that have visited the site or travelled
along its boundary towards wells born
you'll be aware of the Dutch bond
development directly opposite which is
sought to mix a modern and modern
architectural design into an old
redundant farm building both sites are
very much part of the same landscape the
same setting and would complement each
other and fit comfortably into that
landscape considering the heritage asset
this site is not within the conservation
area and indeed there is no report from
our conservation team for this proposal
one can only assume that they are
satisfied with it to my mind the
proposal very much fits in with its
location and is set far enough away from
owning any heritage assets and not to
cause any harm but to enhance the
character and the setting of the
conservation area through its good
design and bringing otherwise
dilapidated buildings back into a viable
use with absolutely no objections raised
from any statuary consulting neighbors
or relevant parties and the parish
meeting I would encourage you to support
this application as to my mind for the
reasons I've given it does accord with
the core strategy of politcs
8 9 15 20 and 8/10
have I got no more time left I believe I
will do so I would make the point of the
parish it's not a pressure council there
apparently meeting they only meet twice
a year they tend therefore not to make
too many comments on planning
applications I have spoken to them a
number of times about this and they have
verbally confirmed their support to it
regrettably they couldn't be here
tonight no no they wanted to come in
July but right away regrettably again
they weren't able to but they do support
it's also worth noting for cancer the
bonds is a benefit we pulled up putting
up the photos we had before it was your
your reports so these here if you look
at the top particularly at the top right
image you can see all the glazed
frontages etc etc etc now if you
wouldn't mind he's only going to your
pictures you've had a series of pictures
of the
and there was one of the white building
with glaze from that one they're very
mindful that's the style that's there
now they're very much seeking to
maintain what is there and actually you
know bring in that modern contemporary
look
police supported every Thank You
councillor Giles it's the Dutch barn
you're referring to that's in the
vicinity the one on the Stratford Road
just if where the crossing to the
airfield
we can show you on the map if you bring
up the red lines right please so just
before you turn in so there's another
one that's close in that one left that
building there where the mouse is now
that's the Dutch barn that I was
referring to so it's directly offers it
and very mean you've seen it the look of
it and how it fits in my personal view
is that what's been proposed is much
more relevant and a much better design
in terms of combining the original and
sort of more modern contemporary care
about I was going to say well we've got
the map up but how far is this cut the
conservation area from the listed in the
chocolate park so you can see there the
Purple Line is chocolate parks garden oh
that's that's the actual field and so
that's the heritage asset it's outside
that boundary but it does back on so you
know again National Trust haven't
objected verbally there again they've
said that they have no particular issue
but they have no okay any other
questions thank you very much
questions to the officers councillor
Giles it's quite complex site and I I
can see from your report there are
actually a number of quite a number of
reasons for your refusal and it flows
through the report so I'm just wondering
if you could provide a summary summary
really of your reasons of refuser so I
can just understand the crux of it and
what your your main issues are and what
you feel that this
if you continues pertaining to the site
okay say within within policy
particularly policy a s10 does allow for
the conversion to a resident reuse of
redundant or dish's buildings in open
countryside in such cases residential
should be the only viable use and the
building should be capable of conversion
in a manner that is appropriate to its
character in setting and then also
within other policy documents with
within the district for example the
district design guide refers to
conversion of bonds and the conversion
of violence should be done in it
sympathetic manner to be able to
maintain the character of the historical
farmstead in this instance it's
considered in my opinion that the
extensions and the proposed development
is too expensive and going away from the
historic character of the farmstead that
we have before us also where it is in
its location as a result of the size the
bulk and the design that then has an
impact on the adjoining heritage assets
and landscape features particularity
views into and out of child cut Park
does that help okay so repairing thank
you chair
I just would welcome some clarification
from the officers I'm actually quite
familiar with this particular site a
because it it borders on to my ward area
and I can certainly remember when it's
part of the site actually operated as a
pine shop as a commercial operation so
therefore would I be right in thinking
that
it's brownfield because it was
commercial because it has operated a lot
of the farm buildings were used for the
manufacturer of pine furniture and I
have bought several things that are
actually certainly we're in a fault
former home of mine so I view a shop as
being commercial and therefore
brownfield could I have some
clarification as I sit here this evening
I have no information to answer that
question I'm sorry I was it may well
have been used for therefore it may well
be brownfield land and that's one factor
that you'll need to take into account in
reaching your decision along with all
the design guide advice that Amy's
referred to including one I think you
overlooked which is that barn
conversions shouldn't involve extensions
it dilutes
and harms the no other questions can't
yes you have a question there question
so we're going to debate councillor
Charles yes this is copy it's okay it's
a complex site and I think nobody is I'm
sure the argument is going to be made
well you know we need to bring it back
into life and use that's not the
question here no issue about that the
reality is this is a multi-million pound
development and in my opinion it
deserves to be got absolutely right it
adjoins a grade two star list
property and garden and landscape that
is of national significance so I think
the starting point is if we have a
planning officer who tells us on
multiple grounds that this development
causes her concern I think we have to
tread incredibly carefully because we
have a huge responsibility
this is an open landscape the reference
was made to that Dutch barn as far as
I'm concerned that barn sticks out like
a sore thumb and it's incredibly
noticeable and it is not in keeping in
the slightest if this development is
going to look anything like that I have
grave concerns I'm afraid now this is
not about rejecting contemporary design
and actually I would say design is not
subjective we have guidelines for reason
if who's almost subjective there would
be no guidelines and we would all just
sit around here and go do we like it do
we not do we like contemporary design do
we not know design is not subjective we
have a planning officer who is here and
is skilled to give us advice about
whether the design fits in with the
planning you know the planning thing so
there are just a few things I would like
you know commit to take into account
because what I think we should be doing
as a committee with a with a development
of this scale in such a sensitive
location is we should be felt happy a
hundred percent happy and we should have
a planning office who is telling us you
know what yeah this is a really
sensitive great conversion it might be
modern it might be contemporary but
actually it's really fitting and really
in keeping and I think committee really
has to look at some things in here that
I think are very significant so page 57
it says whilst it at the bottom
paragraph loss it's noted that the
southern range would be retained for
plot seven retaining the farmstead
character cumulatively it's considered
that the proposed works particularly the
additional bulk and change in height
would lead to an unacceptable loss of
character which is not in accordance
with cs20 then to look at page 59 for
paragraphs from the top bottom sorry it
said as I think miss foots pointed out I
consider that it's been demonstrated
that residential is
only viable use yes nobody's debating
that but party requires the building to
be comforting in a manner that is
appropriate to the character in the
setting it then goes on to say at the
bottom it's considered the modern
treatment of the elevations and the
addition of the large modern dormer
windows larger proportions of
fenestration opportunities to avail the
original character have been missed it
then goes on to say in relation to the
double garage it would be overly
prominent due to its modern design
visually intrusive and would not be
considered to preserve and enhance the
character of the locality the
development will be visible from both
the greatest are registered park and
Crocket parked and the roads that
approached the side it would
unacceptably change the character of the
proposed development read in the context
of the application you know I have to
say that's just not what I want to see I
want to see that one of the most
sensitive conversions of as I said
multi-million pound felon is going to be
done in a way that we can be told you
know what it's modern it's fresh but
actually it's retaining that fundamental
characteristic and when I looked I just
went if you have the elevations of the
current extent and proposed no actually
it was there draught the drawings of the
elevations yeah so the top is the
existing and we can see a lot of
detailing a lot of feature the planning
the applicant describes the extent which
is that middle line as pastiche I'm
sorry but actually I think that that is
it's a conversion it's but it creates
and retains that link with the past
there is no doubting that what is at the
bottom here is just something completely
new and I have to say the committee
should be a little bit cynical because
if you look at the elevation which is
the second from the bottom that's last
year's application this committee said
no it's come back what are the
substantial changes that doesn't seem to
be any difference to me and the problem
that I have is that you know actually
it's called pastiche but one could also
argue that word means it's been
it's somebody put in an application at
some point which recognized it was
desirable to keep its agricultural
character you know I would actually say
that you could argue that this current
design it's trite
yes it's very contemporary it's very
2010 but actually it's going to look
very 2010 in 20 30 years it might be
like wow it's glazed it's a bit of
wooden cladding it's it's it's now it's
not telling us anything about what was
going on in the 18th century and I just
think that's such a shame so you
probably would have gathered by my
rather strong opinion but I I would
propose refusing this because I think
the officer has looked at this in a very
detailed way and for me it's not a
matter of subjectivity do you like it or
do you not it's it's it's a real issue
about planning consideration and I
respect the opinion off the officer gosh
thank you I'm going to catch the Barnes
now I was here when this came before and
that was the reason I asked about 2 3 &
4 in the respect that they have been
substantially improved in my eyes
very limited effect on the conservation
area or the area down here although the
last speaker you know didn't agree with
that I appreciate their barn shouldn't
have bits on them but we've got to try
and save these bonds I've got two barns
falling down because the plan is oh we
don't want this and we don't want that
than the architect and and we're losing
them so as far as I'm concerned I think
the second or third go if you want to
put it that way because I've seen it
twice he's a major improvement and I
would be I would be happy to support it
because I think a lot of the things that
were addressed put down before have been
addressed sometimes old and new goes
together and looks good we've had funny
materials on different things so as far
as I'm concerned I did go look at this
life after the last application because
I didn't know it at all to be honest but
as far as I'm concerned I'll give it a
whirl I'll propose for proof okay well
we had a proposal ready but Chancellor
Perry thank Thank You chair I actually
sat on the committee back in July and
refused this application but I'm
heartened by this new application
because I think they have addressed some
of our design needs I also feel to me
it's a brownfield site because I have
bought furniture there and there's been
a lot of trade going on there at the
moment they are derelict buildings
I wonder councillor Giles have you
actually been to the site no we're not
we're not talking about I just wanders I
just it's just interesting because it is
a whole group of different buildings
which are falling down I also want to
point out it's very rare that we have an
application that comes forward to us
where there is absolutely no objection
the ward member is supporting it I do
understand or believe that the the
charcut parish council though it's not
like run like a cup proper parish
council are in support of it certainly
there's no objection from child carpark
and and actually taking on board
councillor Richards views particularly
with the hideous Dutch bomb that is
opposite it would it would give a
greater balance if you're coming from
Stratford as an attractive development
into the Gateway of Wales born so I
would be happy
just to second counselor bonds proposal
to the application we have a previous
cancer crumble yeah next on this one and
perhaps disagree against the jars
regarding design because sometimes
beauties in the eye of the beholder so I
think there is some subjective
confirmation there yeah again definitely
mixed on this we've got the ward member
sporting no objections
we've got anecdotal evidence that the
parish meeting in child could Park
support it and I've got no reason to
disbelieve cancer riches on this what
would have been good if the been some
email confirmation of that both from the
target park and the parish meeting just
to confirm that and again in my line of
business I'll work on evidence so that
would have helped and again it's the
brownfield site as well again had the
evidence because we are slightly
confused catch the Paris and it could
been and again I've no reason to
disbelieve case the party because you
kicked me if I did but again if we've
got that evidence there I would just be
slightly happier to go along and
supporter on this I would disagree with
Amy we're on page 65 basis there's no
public benefit and whether or miss read
that or misunderstood because we've got
potentially significant contributions
from public open space in enabling and
potentially sill so there are some
merits there as well but it's catch the
Williams as if it's not quite right it's
wrong on the balance of probability if
I'd got this extra evidence I would have
gone against officers recommendation but
I'm not sure now now it's okay
on my discretion so go ahead what did
you want to say very briefly if you want
to do it now or later because you get
one shot
yeah just for clarity on the brownfield
site thing and you're asking for
evidence my understanding is that a
brownfield site is one that has been pre
developed so this there is a dwelling on
the sites there as holiday lets on the
site there is an extract permission that
in itself and the officers will correct
me if I'm wrong I'm sure does give it
that brownfield sites days okay I think
that's more discussion that that was
more of a question to officers and they
can put okay thank you
yeah right just hang on we're going to
when you come back on that on the brown
fed I'm not sure what difference it'll
makes if you do come back on the ground
field offices I I'd like to know what
more difference it makes
councillor Atkinson I think one of the
issues here we must remember that both
the NPP F and the core strategy
encourages and invites initiative in
design I think that has been achieved
here it looks very good one is seeing a
actual reduction in the number of units
compared with what can exist at the
present time I can't see anything wrong
with it
it's good to have innovation it seems to
fit well and I think one of the most
important points is that the neighbor of
importance has raised no objection I
think one or two other points I'd like
to point out actually it will bring to
your attention is the distance from
wells bomb there is some common there
that their journey from wells borne is
1.5 kilometers therefore it's not
sustainable or anything of that nature
now I looked at an appeal actually and
there it's a very very similar thing
conversion in building and one of the
objections of the District Council was
that the distance from shell field to
wooden world was 2.7 kilometers well
that is well within it and if an
inspector
that has been satisfactory it's good
enough for me also in other appeals the
change in get a to to property of this
nature has a better impact on the
sustainability of local businesses
because compared with holiday let's
residents are likely to use facilities
on a greater scale and more frequently
than those who are there for the
enjoyment of a couple of days or
something of that nature I can't see
anything wrong with this I do think it's
something which we ought to welcome it's
providing some housing which we need
notwithstanding the claims about what we
have got by 6.2% in this supply figure
there's a heck of a greater demand than
that
certainly this chairman has my support I
hope the support can stir Perry yes Jay
I just wanted to come back because I I
now recollect I was present at the child
parish meeting November 2017 when this
first came forward to the parish and I
can remember at that time quite vividly
they they all seemed quite excited about
it okay thank you so coming back for the
officers proposed and I'm go to second
counselor Charles's proposal to go with
the officer recommendation so we had a
proposer we've now got a seconder we're
going to hear one comment from the
officers and then we'll take a vote okay
thank you
enormous number of points there to
address
I won't address all of them I promise
you picking up on counselor Barry's
question on previously developed land
I won't read the full definition but
quickly land which is or was occupied by
a permanent structure including the
curtilage of the developed land though
it should not be assumed that the whole
of the curtilage should be developed and
any associated fixed surface
infrastructure this excludes land that
is always last up occupied by
agricultural or forestry buildings so on
the basis of the evidence that
councillor Perry gave it is probably
brownfield land but on today sitting
here I cannot confirm that I don't have
the background information and anecdote
really isn't sufficient for us to rely
on to go forward and make a planning
decision but it could be previous for
development it could be brownfield land
that's the first point the second point
is that the the principle of this
development rests on this being the only
viable use and I understand that there
is a previous permission for all of the
accommodation there's a lot of demand
for holiday accommodation in this area
all of the accommodation is causes it's
not residential although it's the same
used mass and the final point is that
the building should be capable of
conversion in a manner that's
appropriate to its character and setting
that of course is a is a decision for
members to make the final point that I
would like to make is if members are
considering granting planning permission
here the reasons for refusal that you
see in front of you are the reasons for
refusal but members used last time this
application came in front of them and
what I think members need to be entirely
satisfied upon is that each of those
reasons for refusal has been addressed
in these changes that Amy has pointed
out here in front of you the the changed
of gap between those two units the
removal of those garages but those
together overcome all of those concerns
set out in
those reasons for shizzle thank you okay
so that's a very pond we are going to
need to give reasons why your this this
application with the blue circles is
better than the old application which we
refused so we have a proposal a second
to go with the offered recommendations
to refuse this application all those in
favor all those against abstaining
so casting vote I'm afraid we are going
to refuse this application in line with
the officers recommendation and our
final application tonight thank you
no I'm happy with that
yeah okay so thank you very much for
turning up and waiting but it's good
news
there's no objectors turn up so
application 18 well for the Navin 18:02
75 eight old Rico suave unable to the
garage
no one's turn up to object which was the
reason it's at committee so are
proposing we delegate this as an officer
grant and we all in favor of that yeah
great no thank you very much and before
we go we have to get a time for our
cybers it a day for our side visit we
we've got another site visit so what
about the day before the next
application the next committee meeting
do you think yeah I like miles away the
last time we stood yet is a good
starting point that the day of the next
committee 30th the 30th of January can
you do the 30th Molly
yes sir dr. Cody sorry thank you